for those that might not be familiar as
we start just explain
how how walkaway started what is it yeah
um yeah i think i can do kind of an
elevator pitch version of that
so obviously i was myself a lifelong
liberal
um a democrat voter through 2016.
um and i think i started voting in 20
well in 2000
i believe uh yeah yeah and so i always
voted democrat and i did it pretty
thoughtlessly too i mean even if i
didn't know who
the candidate was or whatever just i
would go in and check anything with a d
next to it basically and um for me
the i think the the greatest um reason
why i was drawn to do that is because
i'm gay
and because the messaging and the
marketing i think of the democrats in
the liberal media and the whole
you know leftist machine very
effectively
is that you know republicans are the
party of greedy self-interested straight
white people
and democrats are the only people who
care about marginalized
communities in this country like black
people brown people lgbt people etc
and so i sort of thoughtlessly
considered myself a liberal
and and thoughtlessly was voting
democrat
and then in 2016 i was very excited to
vote for hillary clinton which i did
and i was terrified well okay
i was you know it was a big joke
basically that trump was running for
office until it became clear that he was
going to win the primary and actually
become the candidate and then it's like
it changed overnight from it being
really funny to suddenly
hitler is running from yeah like
overnight that ann coulter clip from
bill maher
yes when everyone's laughing at her when
she says trump yeah
that's it yeah that is that's such a
crowning moment for her i feel like to
be like the only person who was right
at that moment to get laughed at yeah
wow yeah
but um so i bought into all of it i mean
even when they changed the narrative
very quickly which i think that they did
um i know it sounds a little bit
conspiratorial but i mean i do believe
that the
that the media kind of bands together to
you know create the
the the narratives and the manipulation
and you know whatever it is that
you know what what they're going to be
pushing in terms of you know the
narrative of the story
and so suddenly it became trump's a
racist trump's a bigot trump's a
homophobe trump's a monster and so are
his
uh followers and so we have to eliminate
this guy that's what i think they were
going with
so when he got elected president i was
shocked and confused and
outraged but more than anything i was
scared i was terrified
because i really did believe that you
know as a gay man i really watched our
culture
change during the obama years by you
know when obama went and i'm not saying
that's because of obama don't get me
wrong
but i'm saying when obama started uh
there was still a lot of
blatant homophobia that was happening
and a lot of resistance to you know
marriage equality things like that right
but by the time
he left um if you were to believe the
the media
uh basically we'd kind of overcome those
things everything and change which
actually i do think that we have but
when trump became popular again what
they were saying was no this is a
backlash to all the progress that we
made under obama and now
trump wants to reverse your rights as a
gay person he wants to send black people
back to africa
pence wants to throw us all into
concentration camps in pennsylvania and
shock us all straight and i i did hear
all those things to be
like no yeah it's some form of that yeah
no i mean it's absurd and obviously i'm
you know not coming across as a great
genius here but like i
i bought into the vast majority of all
of it i was like
you know and so i was scared and i
wanted to
um part of me wanted to punish his base
for voting for him uh but the other part
of me wanted to just stop being
so scared and angry and confused and and
outraged and all these things so i kind
of went on this journey of research
god this is a terrible elevator pitch is
the show even are the two hours
so um i kind of went on this journey uh
to try to understand
two things how how did the media get it
so wrong because the media that i
trusted told me he had like a three
percent chance of winning or less
and why would anybody vote for somebody
who's so terrible like you know yes
republicans are obviously the worst
people in the world
but i didn't think they were that bad
you know right right and uh
so i started kind of researching it and
in january of 2017
right around the time he was about to
take office i posted something on social
media that ended up
changing my life forever and i didn't
know that it was going to but
again i you know i wanted to punish
people who voted for him and so
i was constantly putting out these
really nasty posts and you know talk
you guys are such idiots and thanks for
ruining the world and you know whatever
but in january i posted that i would
never be able to understand
how anyone could vote for a man who was
capable
of standing before a cheering crowd and
mocking a reporter's disability
right like what happened to the to the
decency and the soul and
just the humanity of middle america like
what is wrong with you guys
and and somebody finally answered me
because i was putting all these nasty
posts out but
like no one would respond right right i
was like answer me why did you vote for
him
tell me you know and like no one would
so finally on uh
privately on facebook this woman named
diane hi diane
beck uh my babysitter oh i didn't even
look at the camera hi dad
um she she reached out to me privately
and she just said look i'm not trying to
start anything with you like i'm not
because we'd had a lot of fights
she's a staunch christian conservative
your eyes are just really fixed
because brandon brandon's a slammer on
the table
the ufo keeps falling i'll try to i'll
just
so that's not better uh
she reached out to me privately and she
said um i'm not trying to start a fight
with you
i'm just asking have you seen this and
she sent me a link to a youtube video
entitled debunking the trump mocked the
disabled reporter have you seen it
i did okay because of you actually yeah
we were talking about this last night
wow i pride myself on somebody who
tries to avoid falling for the narrative
traps and all that yeah but it was
actually a video you posted
where i was like wait he wasn't mocking
the republicans no he wasn't
i i thought he was no and and i'm
somebody who is always like
i i will talk with trump supporters i
don't say i don't think they're all that
bad i don't think trump's all that bad
but that was something i thought was
true until i saw your video yeah you
know it's
when you just said that right now i even
again i got chills
because i for me it's not just a moment
it's the moment that changed my life
it completely changed my life and so
okay so yeah what's the gist of the
video
so uh it's a it's a compilation video
showing donald trump
in certain circumstances even before he
was running for president you know
when he was like on larry king uh early
2000s or something
but it's a it's a compilation of six
seven eight times
when he did that exact same voice and
gesture as he did at that rally which is
basically like oh
yeah and he goes oh with his arm then
he's flailing yeah he's flailing
and but in every single circumstance
he's imitating somebody
who's flailing because they were caught
in a lie right or doing something shady
or doing something dishonest
but on that day he happened to be doing
it
imitating somebody who really did have a
disability but
the media knew i mean they covered every
rally that he did
and he's done this numerous times at his
rallies and i think he was imitating ted
cruz at one point i think he was
imitating
uh several different people the exact
same voice and gesture
but what they did was they freeze framed
when his arm was like this
and they threw it up on the television
screen with a banner that said trump
mocks disabled reporter
yeah and i thought it was one of the
most shocking shocking
sickening things i'd ever seen in my
entire life and for me
it should have ended there why would
anyone be willing to vote for somebody
who
who would make fun of a disabled person
in front of thousands of cheering people
and um but i watched this video and i
had to watch it three times because i
had this like
disconnect kind of between my brain and
my heart because
my brain was going oh my god i don't
think he mocked that reporter's
disability and my heart was going yeah
but we hate him
but we hate him like and i don't want to
see something that makes it harder for
me to hate him
and so i watched it three times in a row
and i couldn't make sense of it and
so i went to bed and i i just kind of
told myself okay you can watch it again
later don't you don't have to make sense
of it right now
it kept me up almost all night and i
woke up the next day and i opened my
computer and i watched it again first
thing and it was like crystal clear he
didn't mock
a reporter's disability but this
presented an even bigger conundrum for
me because if he didn't mock a
reporter's disability
why did cnn tell me that he did and what
else didn't he do
what what other things the media claimed
oh oh oh right right right i thought
that was
like a quiz um oh no no he didn't call
on mexicans rapists
he didn't uh create very fine man
well but charlottesville hadn't happened
yet right right charlottesville was the
first
incident that i saw happen in real time
after i walked away
and well so so that's what started this
like disconnect for me that oh my god
there's something wrong here
and so i started kind of researching how
often does this happen like what
what other things that they lied about
every day yeah everything
and i found i i talk about this one a
lot because i found this really
interesting footage of it it wasn't any
like uh you know
social media influencers or famous
people or anything but it was a group of
black people
who had gone to a trump rally to support
him and when they got there they
situated themselves in the seats
and then cnn moved the camera
so that they wouldn't be in the shot and
they said they were outside of the after
the
the
rally was over they were being
interviewed by people and they were like
cnn just completely moved the camera
when we sat down in front of them
because god forbid
people would see black people supporting
trump that shatters the white
supremacist narrative right
there's a meme right now and it says if
they're claiming this man is a nazi and
this woman is a white supremacist
they're trying they're they're
brainwashing you and it's ben shapiro
and candace owens right
yeah and it's i i mean look yeah so
i remember i watched you you put up the
video i remember exactly when
where you mentioned your your walk away
moment and it was that clip
and it showed donald trump doing the uh
you know thing and then i
i thought oh oh like he he did make
i thought he made fun of the disabled
guy but he wasn't imitating him for
being disabled
i didn't realize he did it to a bunch of
other people and that was a normal trump
thing
exactly but when i saw that i laughed
because i was like
you know the fact that he would still
mock and laugh that way and kind of
flail around
me says to me that he is bad but not
that bad
not not in the way they claim he is you
know my thing has always been
trump in my opinion is not the uh the
character
you you expect to see in the in the oval
office right and so that i've had an
issue with
the way he would demean people make fun
of people and
i think one thing i've been been seeing
recently is
he's been improving i mean he did have
the um
the joe scarborough thing earlier this
you know not too long ago yeah
i'm not a fan of that stuff i don't like
when he you know rails on people that
way
but i've been looking i've been watching
his press conferences i've been paying
attention and he's chill
he's way chill way more chill now than
he was and for me
that was kind of a big deal not that my
my vote is determined based on whether
or not someone's a potty mouth
sure but it does play a does play some
kind of role can i ask you a question
absolutely why don't you like it when he
does that
i think you've got a lot of very so um
it's not professional i'm not i'm not
saying it's the worst thing in the world
are you hr tim no no no and
and and i've had these conversations
with trump supporters notably does the
president need to be
a perfect character a perfect image
should i care if trump is acting this
way if he's fixing the country and i'm
absolutely you're completely right so
policy does come first but
uh so i'm not saying you know it's the
one thing that really does stop me
early on in his in his look he hired
john bolton that was a mistake
he had the missile strike in syria and i
said here we go all of it you know he
was going to be this this guy now he's
not
but he's he's greatly improved and we
can talk about in a second
but uh you know i don't know so so ask
me the question again
well i was just asking why you don't
like it when he
writes does those things says those
things acts that way
one one thing is i'm not a big fan of
inefficiency
and i think if you've got a bunch of
people that are looking for excuses
stop giving them excuses you know try
and try and figure out how to navigate
this properly
and it seems like we often hear about
trump playing 4d chess
where he successfully manipulates and he
does these things that triggers and
makes them look crazy
i laugh i laugh i do look i i've i think
trump is a great entertainer
and i think he's a very very funny guy
but i feel like
he could be he he could well actually i
feel like he is
starting to do it he's starting he's
starting to actually uh play a better
role
maybe his history or the smears against
him will will you know
hold him back quite a bit but i was
always thinking like i've said this
several times if the democrats put
forward someone with trump's policies
but didn't do this kind of you know
bombastic behavior they'd probably win
absolutely well and i the reverse could
have been said in the past too
i mean because i always used to think
republican you know as a democrat now as
a liberal i thought to myself i actually
think that republicans in many ways have
better policies
but they have such terrible uh pr in a
way you know i mean they they're
they're such a toxic image that
republicans have but this kind of
brings it full circle because the reason
why i asked you that question
about why don't you like it is because i
didn't
used to like it either i mean this is
someone who literally hated trump
and then i you know something that's
important for people to understand is
i didn't walk away from the left
straight into trump's arms
i mean there was i i made a decision in
in march of 2017 was the day
the final straw for me was when rachel
maddow got on twitter
and said i've got his tax returns i've
got his tax returns no really i've got
tax returns
now i've been researching for two months
up until this point
uh like religiously and i had found
just a whole bible full of examples
of the media lying manipulating
race-baiting
using uh you know uh hate crime hoaxes
things like this it was all piling up
for me and i was literally like
completely out the door and then all of
a sudden rachel maddow gets on twitter
and she says i've got his tax returns
i've got tax returns and i thought to
myself
this is really bad but i'm just i'm
being honest
i was like okay if i tune in tonight and
she's got some smoking gun about his tax
shirts i'm gonna forget about everything
i learned the last two months
and i'm gonna get right back on the i
hate trump train i'm just gonna like
cognitive dissonance i'm just gonna
pretend like it didn't happen
like that's literally was my mentality
and i really thought there was a chance
too
so like and she did that pretty early in
the day so we all had to wait like hours
to until her show was on
so we sit there and i'm sure you saw it
oh yeah she vamped for about 45 minutes
just
literally talking gibberish about
nothing and then finally in like the
last segment of her show she produced
two pieces of paper
which showed that he paid his taxes in
two thousand like 35 million dollars or
something
she got roasted for this because it made
trump look
good yeah and one of the one of the
conspiracy theories was that the trump
camp
actually seated these because they knew
she couldn't resist
and they knew it would make trump look
good and it would it would do exactly
what you experienced
yes that you you she was it was it was
total bunk
yes real quick do you know that uh you
know you know about the durham report
they're they're investigating the
investigators for russia gate okay
rachel maddow was
obsessed every day russia russia russia
well we got we got big news rachel they
actually arrested a lawyer who was
i guess essentially fabricating evidence
to go after trump
and she didn't cover it interesting
that's the game that's the game
yeah i look i i you know i've worked for
these media companies i i know what
they're interested in
and it's not honesty it's attention it's
it's anger it's rage
so all of these fake stories about trump
it's a gold mine for them
well and then the other thing that
they'll do too is if the opposition
ends up finding evidence of their own
wrongdoing then they just start
attacking the character of the
opposition or
you know planting seeds of doubt in the
evidence uh i mean
she's crazy that woman's insane i mean
she was
during the russian thing she was i
watched her show a couple of times you
could only stomach it a few times but
i watched a few of her shows and she was
going back i mean she was really
obsessing about nixon
and trying to draw a connection between
trump and nixon and you know
and that's basically i think that she
knew that the evidence was so
flimsy or evidence you know against
trump that what she tried to do was get
everyone all riled up about
nixon and then just be like oh and by
the way trump's like nixon you know and
that would be the intervention
transfer all that hate over like build
it up and then send it to trump right
right thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show
live monday through friday at 8 pm if
you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you